give you three things now that I'll
start rewiring neural Pathways please go
get up in the morning
get up early in the morning not early
just get up in the morning if you get up
at seven o'clock eight o'clock go
straight into the bathroom
if you brush your teeth with your right
hand start brushing with the left look
into the mirror now we're talking to the
subconscious brain eye to eye in the
mirror and say I love you
ten times when you finish that let's get
some oxygen inside you to start the day
exaggerated breaths to start the day how
many breaths I always tell my guys do 25
in the morning 25 lunchtime 25 in the
evening
okay so left-handed teeth brushing yes
look straight in the eye in the mirror I
love you I love you I love you ten times
yes and exaggerated breaths 25. change
your life